er packt er backt beweg dich schamlos es
geht zunächst bekommen zu einem neuen
junioren der ndr games mal wieder sind
ganz ganz ganz langer zeit und ich habe
wieder lust so nach diesem kleinen
biester aber so dankeslied oder andere
wieder vergessen mag es auch nämlich
gerade und zocken in unserem kleinen ich
darf er nicht projekt sagen sondern in
unserer welt die bilder zusammenhang
müssen weiter ich bin heute mit dem
känguru kate soll ich das früher mal
gemacht habe vor vielen vielen
jahrzehnten oder auf einer sechs monate
sechs monate da habe ich sehr sehr
regelmäßig an der games gespielt aber
ich hatte heute ein verlust probieren so
haben wir natürlich viel muskeln machen
weil die alten zweifel games ist ja auch
für euch dann nicht dieselbe abwechslung
wenn man die mauern gespräche modi
bringt deswegen gibt heute mailänder
games schreibt mir einfach mal in die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet
fehlender games ist tot
kann man das nicht mehr anschauen so oft
gesehen oder denkt ihr ja das würde ich
mir noch angucken
warum macht das keiner mehr mach mal
neue kids oder so keine ahnung wer bock
hab ich würde auch gerne ein paar von
diesen kids ausprobieren hierbei
größtenteils noch gar nicht gespielt
ehrlich gesagt ja wir können es keine
angst machen bereichert da oben ist eine
schöne alte tat ja genau genau er sagt
hat es gesehen beim chat schöne alte
zeiten wieder holen mit ender games
genau so ist es
ich bin auch gerade in so einer
nostalgischen stimmung deswegen geben
uns das ja jetzt
19 änderungen auf android ja da finden
wir locker die festung halten also ein
bisschen auf dem laufenden unser
nächstes ziel ist nämlich der länder
daten zu kämpfen was du redest die ganze
krise ich weiß nicht was das ist
ich hab nur das ist das neue projekt von
denen acht entschädigt hat mir aber ich
weiß gar nicht was das ist ehrlich
gesagt so dar dass der nächste weg wo
ist es so viel lucia wiederum bauens
alter später habe ich erfahren bekommen
nämlich nicht bekommen leider der hier
so tut manchmal in pumpkin pie reihe
tendieren wir auch schon lange nicht
mehr gegessen weil sich im cockpit zu
kräften ist im single player oder im
survival-modus gar nicht so wie sie ohne
mich verdammt viel zeug und ich hab das
ding voll in der fresse hatte ich mal
ein bisschen zeit so zeitlich zeitlich
ich habe zeit ich seitdem ich ist und
die aluminum schwert gerne haben wo er
muss an den gold abwehrreihen
das ist hier sperrt wunderbar molto bene
darunter sind auch zwei youngster im
team oder gut aber dafür wo ich euch
sich zumindest mal seinen kollegen auch
sehr gut den aber auch moment mal wie
viele dias haben wir nicht so viel
erinnern bessere displays jerusalem
so 47 bis zur nächsten runde ist bisher
richtig richtig knackig nur der kängurus
motiv nicht
ich hab' ich bin nicht da reingehen
sollen diesen kampf jetzt bitte warum
kein gramm verpackt er backt beweg dich
bewegen sich junge ja aber das hängt
dann auch schon jetzt geht es jetzt
geht's wieder wegkommt greift den
anderen an chrysler für den anderen an
ich bin unschuldig bin und ich für dich
junge aha ist eine hektik leicht
verbogen
aber dieser punkt ist auch verdammt
verpackt alter mann ergreift auch
unbedingt jetzt mich an warum er wurde
getauscht glaube ich
jetzt schnell vor ort kennt mich das
froh ist dass gute und dann natürlich
bäckerei ja ja ich weiß jetzt immerhin
reck ich jetzt mal pro tag der date up
ja ich weiß noch nicht mal ein bogen ist
habe ich ein
ich glaub die sklaverei bringt gar
nichts man muss kurz warten dann dafür
jumpy dies hängt nein dass wir ankommen
dass mich entkommen
jo erschießen verbogen nein
woher er das sehr gut das ist sehr sehr
gut
hektik mächtig mikrofon in der kritik so
kann es machen
da habe ich das nicht so die rechnung
gesicht ach du scheiße jetzt erst mal
gucken ob wir im bogen
nein wir haben wir noch paar jackpots
die können - ganz nützlich werden
bitte nicht wagen hierbei schob ich
danke dir okay da kommt der andere
wir machen das jetzt noch was jetzt
dirigent porsche vorher essen aber dafür
bleibt man derzeit ja als ob er mich von
da oben trifft
wtf
knapp knapp und der sprung pax bank
nicht rumliegen porsche rheins langsam
ein bisschen besser karten und der
sprung ist bisschen zu lassen bei dem
etwas besser gestern spazieren als land
gibt müssen sie wohl ein bisschen zu
vergewaltigen
aber den nächsten bekommen ja verdammte
hacke jetzt der macht der macht sich
mehr damit der sprung bin ich mensch was
ist das komm jetzt ich kann nicht mehr
sprinten
aber der muss doch so ultra low life
seien also nicht der erste ist es auch
was menschlichen bogen hätte dann wäre
die welt in ordnung
12.12 funktioniert 12 warum das so aber
nicht öfter drücke das nicht man muss
irgendwie hier neuerdings mit einem
doppelklick dass ihr machen gutes
comeback gegeben
er hat nicht mehr du kannst dich mehr
viele leben haben
ja ok geil yes das war auch der letzte
deswegen ist es weg gelaufen
jetzt erklärt sich mir einiges ja gut
leute mehr richtig gefallen wenn ihr
mehr verändern games sehen wollt dann
lasst gerne daumen nach oben da ich
hoffe ich habe heute jetzt ordentlich
kommentiert weil die runde beim mega
mega action geladen und eigentlich kraft
ich das noch überlebt habe richtig
richtig glück gehabt wenn sich gefahren
was dem daumen nach oben da schreibt man
die kommentare was sie von einer ganz
halten
wir sehen uns im nächsten video wieder
auf 30 und schau